[Music]
North Korean leader Kim Jong-un arrived
in Russia on Tuesday ahead of an
expected meeting with Russian President
Vladimir Putin
it's Kim's first trip abroad since North
Korea gradually reopened its borders
this summer after the covid-19 pandemic
U.S officials said the talks could
Advance ammunition sales between the two
countries as Moscow looks to replenish a
weapon-stuck pile depleted by the war in
Ukraine this meeting is a win-win
situation for Russia and North Korea
here's what Kim and Putin stand to gain
from these talks
Kim crossed into Russia on Tuesday after
a two-day Journey aboard his personal
bulletproof train it is very rare for
the North Korean leader to travel abroad
he does not take many flights usually
takes trains when he is traveling
as the pandemic ended and Kim began
restoring connections with the outside
world he also made a series of prominent
visits inside North Korea to military
facilities
urging the population to prepare for war
[Applause]
experts say he's using these appearances
to mask the country's struggling economy
and severe food shortages after the
country was sealed off for four years
Russia is one of the countries that
could provide North Korea with Aid
especially as it is under Western
sanctions
in August after the leaders of the U.S
South Korea and Japan agreed to hold
joint military drills Kim Jong-un called
the three leaders gang bosses
we made this historic place
to make
a historic moment Kim meeting with Putin
is significant because it shows that
North Korea has powerful allies
especially during a time when the US is
strengthening military cooperation with
Japan and South Korea deploying
strategic assets on the Korean peninsula
having allies like Russia is going to
help Kim explain to his people that we
have countries on our side that will
help us
high-level visits between Russia and
North Korea restarted in July U.S
officials said Russian defense minister
Sergey shoigu's visit was aimed at
convincing Pyongyang to sell ammunition
to Moscow
Russia is facing weapon shortages in
Ukraine and wants to replenish its
stockpile
oh
much of North Korea's weapons are based
on Soviet era of technology which means
they can easily be incorporated into
Russia's existing systems but experts
say what Pyongyang could provide Moscow
is limited most of North Korea's dog
piles are very old modern Weaponry that
North Korea has manufactured in recent
years that are more advanced they can't
be mass produced yet
any arms deal between Pyongyang and
Moscow would violate United Nations
security Council resolutions
the latest meeting between Kim and Putin
shows Russia and North Korea have
continued to grow closer over the years
as both leaders vowed to strengthen
cooperation on all fronts
but the key factor bringing them
together is a common enemy the US North
Korea and Russia have both been
consistent in saying we don't want a
global order that the U.S wants this
Alliance sort of helps Russia and North
Korea builds sort of a counter effort
against the US to say that we have
allies we have neighbors just as much as
the U.S has a military presence in the
region
foreign